This Friday chit-chat is presented by Macy's. Macy's is a no-pressure zone. Here to help you celebrate the little wins and encourage you to feel your best, even when that late January slump kicks in. Shop in store or at Macy's.com. We've started that time where it's like we're in full winter season. I mean, it's been overcast here for like three days. And I feel like during this time, we just want to be cozy.
今天的周五闲聊由梅西百货（Macy's）为您呈现。梅西百货是一个无压力的购物空间。在这里，我们陪伴您庆祝生活中的小确幸，鼓励您保持最佳状态，即使在一月下旬的倦怠期到来时也是如此。欢迎前往实体店或登录 Macy's.com 选购。我们已经进入了一年中全盛的冬季。我是说，这里的阴天已经持续了大约三天。我觉得在这期间，大家只想宅得舒舒服服的。
Mm-hmm. And I can tell you, somewhere. where you can get the coziest things. I had a feeling. You might. Well, Macy's is here to take care of you during these winter months. They have cozy bedding like an ugg reversible faux fur comforter. I have it. You have it?
嗯哼。而且我可以告诉你，某个地方。你能买到最舒适的东西。我有预感。你可能会。好吧，梅西百货会在这些冬日里照顾好你。他们有舒适的寝具，比如UGG可翻转人造毛毛毯。我有这个。你也有？
Yes. It's so dang cozy. It's, I mean, it's like instant warmth, but you also feel like luxurious. Is that the one that's kind of like fuzzy, like kind of furry? Yes. And I like that is reversible. You can like pick which way you want it to go. Macy's has all the things you need to make little changes to your beauty rituals that can make you feel that much better.
对。它太舒服了。我的意思是，它就像瞬间温暖，但你也会感觉很奢华。是那种毛茸茸的、有点像皮草的吗？是的。而且我喜欢它是可翻转的。你可以选择你想用哪一面。梅西百货拥有你所需的一切，让你对美容日常做出小小的改变，让你感觉好得多。
Shop now at Macy's.com or in store. Hello, everyone. Welcome to another Friday chit chat. This is two and one month. Thank you, Macy's. Thanks, guys. You know what? Can I just say before we get going on this chit chat that you look really refreshed.
现在就去 Macy's.com 或实体店选购吧。大家好。欢迎收听又一期的周五闲聊。这是二月的第一期。谢谢你，梅西百货。谢谢你们，伙计们。你知道吗？在我们开始这次闲聊之前，我能说你看起来真的很清爽吗？
Do I? You do. How is your trip to New York? Yeah, I just got back from a little couple's art. artist retreat with Lee. We went to New York. Couples artist retreat. That's what I'm calling it. And I want to do more of these. It was just two days of reading books, seeing theater, eating food, just like immersing in like really cool conversations. I mean, I was reading this book and I came across a line in the book. And I was like, Lee, can we unpack this line? This is you, like, your absolute happy place. I loved it. It was romantic. It was uplifting.
我有吗？你确实有。你的纽约之行怎么样？是的，我和李刚度完一个短暂的情侣艺术。艺术家静修假回来。我们去了纽约。情侣艺术家静修假。我是这么叫它的。我想多来几次这样的旅行。那只是两天的阅读书籍、看戏剧、品尝美食，完全沉浸在非常酷的对话中。我的意思是，我在读这本书时，书中有一句话让我驻足。我说，李，我们能剖析一下这句话吗？这就是你，你绝对的快乐源泉。我太喜欢了。既浪漫又治愈。
We saw this play. We saw bug. It's still out. You can still catch it on Broadway. It was written by Tracy Letts years ago, but it's still like so relevant. This couple, they're in a motel and they start to believe that they're infected with bugs. Oh, gosh. And they are falling in love at the same time.
我们看了这部剧。我们看了《小虫》（Bug）。它还在上映。你还可以在百老汇看到它。这是特雷西·莱茨（Tracy Letts）多年前写的，但现在看依然很有现实意义。这对情侣，他们在一个汽车旅馆里，开始相信自己感染了虫子。哦，天哪。他们同时坠入了爱河。
And to me, there's some stuff I had to watch like through my fingers, like a horror movie, almost. All I can picture is Jim. saying to Dwight, was it smug? Oh, yeah, the smug bed bug? The smug bed bug. You're so right. But no, to me, it's a love story, but it's also like what happens when you get infected with an idea and you're just living in an echo chamber.
对我来说，有些场景我不得不透过手指缝去看，简直就像看恐怖片一样。我脑子里浮现的只有吉姆对德怀特说的那句：是自以为是吗？哦，对，那只自以为是的臭虫？那只自以为是的臭虫。你太对了。不过说真的，对我来说，这是一个爱情故事，但也是关于当你被某种想法感染并生活在回音室里时会发生什么。
It's so good. We absolutely loved it. But yes, I had a great trip. And Angela, that was thanks to you. Oh, come on. It was. I want everyone to know that one of my favorite things about our partnership is how. one of us can go off and have a moment.
太棒了。我们绝对喜欢它。但是是的，我度过了一次很棒的旅行。安吉拉，这多亏了你。哦，少来。真的是这样。我想让大家知道，我们合作中最让我喜欢的事情之一，就是我们中的一个人可以抽身去享受属于自己的时光。
Maybe it's to work on a creative project or even just do a home project or whatever it is. And we've got this other person who keeps the lights on. And you kept the lights on while I was gone. Well, I was happy to do it, lady. You've done that for me so many times. I remember there was a weekend where I was like, I just need to see my mom. I just got to get eyes on her. I remember that.
也许是为了做一个创意项目，或者甚至只是做一个家居项目，无论是什么。而我们有另一个人在坚守阵地。我不在的时候，你一直在坚守阵地。嗯，我很乐意这么做，女士。你为我也做过好多次。我记得有个周末，我说，我只是想见我妈妈。我必须去看她一眼。我记得那次。
And we move things around so I could just go sit with Birdie Joe. I loved it. And I want to give you another shout out, actually, lady. I want to give a shout out to you and to our amazing social media team Block Party. Oh, they're so great. You have been running point on this, and I just have loved what you guys have been doing. Did you tell me recently that we have over 100 million downloads on our reels in less than a year? Views, I guess.
我们调整了行程，这样我就可以去和伯蒂·乔（Birdie Joe）坐在一起了。我太喜欢了。实际上，女士，我想再次向你表达谢意。我要向你以及我们出色的社交媒体团队 Block Party 表达谢意。哦，他们太棒了。这件事一直是由你在统筹，我太喜欢你们所做的一切了。你最近是不是跟我说过，我们在不到一年的时间里，短视频的播放量就超过了 1 亿次？观看量，我猜。
Views? Yes. Not downloads. You don't download a reel. This is why you're in charge of this. No, I mean, I am not that tech savvy. I lean very hard on Claire and Aton at Block Party. They are so fun.
观看量？是的。不是下载量。你不会去下载一个短视频。这就是为什么由你来负责这个。不，我是说，我没那么懂技术。我非常依赖 Block Party 的克莱尔（Claire）和埃顿（Aton）。他们太有趣了。
They have a lot of great ideas. And yeah, we have over 100 million views. And we haven't even been doing reels and stuff for even a year. I know. You know, I just had a meeting with him and I have to tell you something. Lady, I introduced them to my digital clutter. Oh, my gosh. What does that mean?
他们有很多绝妙的点子。是的，我们的观看量已经超过 1 亿了。而且我们做短视频之类的甚至还不到一年。我知道。你知道的，我刚和他们开完会，我必须告诉你一件事。女士，我把我的数字杂乱文件夹拿给他们看了。哦，天哪。那是什么意思？
Well, hopefully I haven't scared them away. I made this folder. I have so many videos from us on set. You do? Behind the scenes, moments, pictures. So they're going to start making some really fun reels with these old little moments of us on set. Lady, I have some of that stuff too.
嗯，希望我没有吓跑他们。我建了这个文件夹。我们有那么多在片场拍的视频。真的吗？幕后花絮、时刻、照片。所以他们打算用这些我们在片场的老旧小片段来制作一些非常有趣的短视频。女士，我也有一些那样的东西。
I got to send it to you because it's priceless. Yeah. Oh, send it. Oh, I love this. Well, speaking of throwbacks, there's actually a really hilarious reel that went up today. And it's one of my favorites. It's from when we were podcasting in our closets during the pandemic. Right.
我得发给你，因为那太珍贵了。好啊，发给我吧。哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，说到回顾过去，今天实际上发布了一个非常搞笑的短视频。这是我的最爱之一。那是我们在大流行期间在衣柜里做播客的时候。对。
It's our John Wick. Our John Wick debate? Yeah, they had a lot of fun putting that together. I was so glad we were over Zoom. I mean, obviously, I would love to be in person with you, but we have this video now. Well, I think it's even funnier when you can see our faces. I love that we have it. It makes me laugh every time.
这是我们的“疾速追杀”（John Wick）。我们的“疾速追杀”辩论？是的，他们把这个剪辑到一起玩得很开心。我很庆幸我们当时是通过 Zoom 连线的。我的意思是，当然，我很想和你面对面在一起，但我们现在有这个视频了。好吧，我觉得能看到我们的表情甚至更好笑。我很高兴我们留下了这个。每次看都让我忍俊不禁。
But I do have something to share about the John Wick debate, a new development. Wait, can I just tell you guys, this is when I wish if we were filming maybe, because Jenna just covered her mouth like, like, what, I have something to tell you. Okay, well, I was in our general mailbox, and I found this letter. We got this letter from Allie X. Ellie X says, Jenna did not say she watched the John Wick movies on the podcast. She just said she was enjoying Keanu Reeves movies, and she might try John Wick next. So I was like, wait.
不过关于“疾速追杀”的辩论，我确实有个新进展要分享。等等，我能先告诉大家吗？这就是我希望我们当时在拍摄的时候，因为珍娜刚才捂住了嘴，就像是，什么，我有话要告诉你。好吧，我在我们的公共收件箱里，发现了这封信。我们收到了来自艾莉 X（Allie X）的信。艾莉 X 说，珍娜并没有在播客里说她看过《疾速追杀》电影。她只是说她很喜欢基努·里维斯（Keanu Reeves）的电影，她接下来可能会尝试看《疾速追杀》。所以我就想，等等。
Because in this video, if you go watch it, or if you guys remember, we get into this whole argument because... I say, Jenna, I did what you told. me, I watched all the John Wick movies. Right. And I'm like, I never said that. Well, Allie X is confirming that I did not say that. So I had a little mom detectives moment and I found the episode of Office Ladies where we first discussed this. Uh-huh. It was in the negotiation. And sure enough, Angela, it's actually your idea that you watch all the John Wick movies. No, no, no. You say something like you're going to be a Keanu Reeves officiado and you're going to watch. I have it. I wrote it down from the transcript.
因为在这段视频里，如果你去看了，或者如果你们还记得，我们陷入了整场争论，因为……我说，珍娜，我照你说的做了。我，我看了所有的《疾速追杀》电影。对。而我说，我从来没说过那话。好吧，艾莉 X 证实了我的确没说过。所以我来了个“妈妈侦探”的高光时刻，我找到了我们第一次讨论这个话题的那期《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）。嗯哼。那是在《谈判》（The Negotiation）那一集。果然，安吉拉，其实是你的主意，由你去看所有的《疾速追杀》电影。不，不，不。你说过类似你要成为基努·里维斯迷并要去看的话。我有记录。我从文字记录里抄下来的。
Okay, let's read it. Okay, I'm saying how Keanu Reeves movies are getting through the pandemic and I say, quote, maybe I'll watch John Wick next. And then, Angela, you say, Josh has seen all of them, but he said you probably shouldn't watch them because they'd be too intense for you. But then you say, quote, maybe I'll watch them with you. and I say, okay, cool. That's it. I clearly took this as marching orders.
好吧，我们来读一下。好吧，当时我在说基努·里维斯的电影是如何帮我们度过大流行的，我说，原话是，“也许我接下来会看《疾速追杀》。”然后，安吉拉，你说，乔什看过所有这些，但他建议你最好别看，因为对你来说太刺激了。但接着你说，原话是，“也许我会陪你一起看。”我说，好的，太棒了。就这样。我显然把这当成了行动命令。
Like, okay, Jenna's going to watch John Wick. I'm going to watch John Wick. Yes. But can I just say I absolutely love how somehow between the two of us, these John Wick movies have now become such a huge part of our friendship. But, you know, something we've never shared on the podcast was how the three of us went and saw John Wick 4 in the theater. I didn't even never even saw 2 or 3.
就像是，好吧，珍娜要去看《疾速追杀》了。那我也要去看《疾速追杀》。是的。但我得说，我太喜欢我们两个不知怎么的，让这些《疾速追杀》电影现在成了我们友谊中如此重要的一部分。但是，你知道，我们在播客里从未分享过的一件事，是我们三个人如何一起去电影院看了《疾速追杀 4》。我甚至从来没看过 2 或 3 部。
I did finally finish all of 1. I started two with you on our book writing retreat, Angela. We didn't finish it. Skipped 3 and then we went to see 4 in the theater in one of those like 4D theaters where you're sitting. Oh my God, the seat was moving the whole entire movie. And there was that long scene at the end. The stairs. Where he can't get up the stairs.
我确实终于看完了整部 1。安吉拉，在我们的写作静修期间，我和你一起开始了第 2 部。我们没看完它。跳过了 3，然后我们去电影院看了 4，在一个那种会动的 4D 电影院里。哦，天哪，整个电影放映期间座位一直在动。而且最后有那么长的一场戏。楼梯。他上不去楼梯。
He can't get up the stairs. That was torturous. percent stares. Yes, it is. He's this poor guy. There's so many stairs. And also, the thing that I grew to really appreciate about the John Watt movie since I've seen them all is how many assassins love a rave.
他上不去楼梯。那太折磨人了。百分之百全是楼梯。是的，确实是。这个可怜的家伙。有那么多楼梯。而且还有，自从我看完了所有的《疾速追杀》电影后，我真正开始欣赏的一点是，有多少杀手喜欢锐舞派对。
And flip phones. Flip phones, but they love to go to a rave. That's where if you want to meet an assassin, go to a rave. They'll be the only ones they're in suits. They're so easy to spot. Yeah. And they're like not dancing. No.
还有翻盖手机。翻盖手机，但他们特别喜欢去锐舞派对。这就是如果你想结识一个杀手，就去锐舞派对。他们会是唯一穿着西装的人。他们太容易被认出来了。是的。而且他们好像都不跳舞。不。
Generally. No. Yeah. My takeaway from it, do you remember he's walking through? it's like an airport and he's shooting at somebody. He's like shooting in like a train station at somebody, but nobody else is aware of it. Nobody's like, hey, that guy is a gun.
通常不跳。是的。我从中的体会是，你还记得他走过吗？就像在一个机场，他在向某人开枪。他在火车站朝某人开枪，但其他所有人都浑然不觉。没有人说，嘿，那家伙有枪。
And then they stab each other on the train. Oh, I don't remember. Is this in four? Was this in four? I think it's the third one. Oh, well, you know, I didn't see that one. I think it's the rave one I'm thinking of. Yeah.
然后他们在火车上互相刺杀。哦，我不记得了。这是在第 4 部里吗？这是在第 4 部里吗？我觉得这是第三部。哦，好吧，你知道的，我没看那部。我想我想到的是有锐舞派对的那部。是的。
So many raves. Yeah. So much running. So much running and running. And then like just everything. And in dress shoes too. Literally like they throw everything at them but the kitchen sink. Like it's like so much.
有那么多的锐舞派对。是的。有那么多的奔跑。跑啊跑。然后就像所有事情一样。而且还穿着正装皮鞋。简直就像他们把能砸的东西都砸过来了，除了厨房水槽。就像是，太多了。
running in dress shoes without orthotics. You know those can't fit in those shoes. Angela, I love that you're worried about is orthotics. That's very you. Well, those dress shoes don't look comfortable to be that athletic in. You're not wrong. Matt, I feel like we need to check in with you. Have you seen the John Wick movies?
穿着没有矫形鞋垫的正装皮鞋奔跑。你知道那些鞋里塞不下鞋垫的。安吉拉，我喜欢你还在担心矫形鞋垫的事。这很符合你的风格。好吧，穿着那些正装皮鞋，做那么剧烈的运动看起来一点也不舒服。你没说错。马特，我觉得我们需要向你确认一下。你看过《疾速追杀》电影吗？
So, guys, I have not seen the John Wick movies. Jenna, can we just be real clear? Is this something I should do? What should I do next? It depends who you ask, I guess. I'm leaving it up to you, Matt. I am definitely not going to mandate that you watch them, but you can see how much fun we're having with it, so I don't know.
所以，伙计们，我没有看过《疾速追杀》电影。珍娜，我们能把话说清楚吗？这是我该做的事吗？接下来我该怎么做？这取决于你问谁，我猜。这由你决定，马特。我绝对不会强制要求你看，但你能看出我们在这上面玩得有多开心，所以，我不知道。
Angela, I want to see how it all works out with the shoes, so I'm in. Okay. Matt, the other thing you should know, I know you're going to, like, check out his shoes and all the running he does, but the thing that Jenna couldn't stop talking about, which is why I think that you would watch them all. all and that I was behind and I needed to go watch them is the little towel that he has his like coffee pot or something next to the coffee pot.
安吉拉，我想看看鞋子的事情最后是怎么解决的，所以我加入。好吧。马特，你还应该知道的一件事，我知道你会去关注他的鞋子和他所有的奔跑，但珍娜一直念念不忘、这也是为什么我觉得你会把它们全看完、而我落后了所以需要去补看的原因，是他在咖啡壶旁边放的那条小毛巾或者别的什么东西。
His mugs. His mugs, what you would sit him on a towel. And lady, I remember the day you came in because my mom had quilted us, these little quilted trivets. Yes. And I had given you one. Yes. And you said, Angela, we put it next to the coffee pot because John Wick does that.
他的马克杯。他的马克杯，你会把它们放在一条毛巾上。女士，我记得你来的那天，因为我妈妈给我们缝制了这些小绗缝隔热垫。是的。我送了你一个。是的。你说，安吉拉，我们把它放在咖啡壶旁边，因为约翰·威克就是这么做的。
You're right. You're right. Yes, so I just have to go on record here. Allie X, you are right. I probably jumped ahead and thought Jenna had watched them all. But if you could have been here, Sam, when she talked about that towel and the little way she used my mom's quilted thing. The way her face lit up, it was like this was the best movie she'd ever seen. If I had only known she was 25 minutes into it.
你说的对。你说的对。是的，所以我必须在这里做个记录。艾莉 X，你是对的。我可能有点操之过急，以为珍娜把它们都看完了。但如果你当时能在场，山姆，当她谈论那条毛巾以及她如何使用我妈妈做的那个绗缝小垫子时。她脸上的光彩，就像这是她看过的最好的电影一样。我要是早知道她才看了 25 分钟就好了。
I know. I was so excited to share about the little towel that I failed to mention that we turned it off. Yeah, that you hadn't actually seen the homework. I was like, oh, I'm behind. I gotta go. Well, like I said, I just love it, and I love that we have this. And if you want to see the video, it's on our Office Ladies' Instagram. But now I think we need to get to our fan chit-chat question.
我知道。我太激动于分享那条小毛巾的事情了，以至于我忘了提我们把它关掉了。对，你其实还没看那部作业。我就像，哦，我落后了。我得走了。好吧，就像我说的，我就是很喜欢，而且我很高兴我们有这个。如果你想看这段视频，它就在我们的《办公室女士》 Instagram 上。但现在我觉得我们需要回答我们的粉丝闲聊提问了。
This one comes from Leah in Connecticut. Hi, Jen and Angela. This is Leah from Trumbull, Connecticut. I'm looking for some kid snack recommendations. My two-year-old gets in snack ruts. What are some quick and easy snacks your kids loved? Love the podcast so much. And a cool office name connection, my mom's name is Debbie Brown and my brother's name is Philip.
这个问题来自康涅狄格州的莉亚。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我是来自康涅狄格州特朗布尔的莉亚。我在寻找一些儿童零食推荐。我两岁的孩子陷入了零食陷入僵局。你们的孩子最喜欢哪些快手又简单的零食？非常喜欢这个播客。还有一个酷炫的办公室同名联系，我妈妈的名字叫黛比·布朗（Debbie Brown），我弟弟的名字叫菲利普（Philip）。
Thank you. Philip and Debbie Brown. Oh, Debbie Brown. That's a deep cut. That is. That's a good one. So, Matt, Jenna, you guys have younger kids. I have teenagers now.
谢谢。菲利普和黛比·布朗。哦，黛比·布朗。那是个深层梗。确实是。这是一个好梗。所以，马特、珍娜，你们都有比较小的孩子。我现在有 teenagers（青少年）了。
But I still remember some of our go-to snacks. Well, I can relate to the snack rut. Yeah. You know, because you'll have something that's tried and true. and everybody loves it, and then one day it's just rejected. No one wants it. Nobody wants that thing anymore. I know, for example, my kids were really into those Trader Joe's Rosemary Crackers.
但我仍然记得我们常备的一些零食。嗯，我对零食陷入僵局感同身受。是的。你知道的，因为你会有一些屡试不爽的东西。每个人都喜欢，然后有一天它就被拒绝了。没人想要了。没人再想要那个东西了。我知道，比如说，我的孩子曾经非常喜欢那些 Trader Joe's 的迷迭香饼干。
It's very sophisticated. I know, but they have that little sweet cranberry or raisin in them, I guess. But those are the crackers that I ate by the boxful during the Angela Martin Bachelorette party when we were on set of the office. And Ellie and I ate so many of them that she sent me a giant jar of them for my birthday as a joke. Yeah. And that's the first time my kids tried them was from the big thing that Ellie sent me. And then they fell in love with them. But then all of a sudden they hit a wall and they would need them anymore.
这很讲究。我知道，但它们里面有那种甜甜的小蔓越莓或葡萄干，我猜。但这些饼干是我在办公室片场拍摄安吉拉·马丁单身派对时，一盒一盒吃光的饼干。埃莉和我吃了太多，以至于她作为玩笑送了我一大罐当作我的生日礼物。是的。这也是我的孩子第一次尝试埃莉寄给我的那个大罐子里的饼干。然后他们就爱上了。但随后突然间他们撞了南墙，再也不肯吃了。
For me, my kids, I have an eight-year-old and a six-year-old. And we get in meal-ruts, snacks. They eat the same snack. Like, I'm wondering if Leah have if the kids have tried cheese it or four. fruit snacks or hula bars. I mean, Leah, our kids love go-go-squeeze. Do you remember go-go-squeeze? It's basically like applesauce, but it's in a little pouch, and they can unscrew the top,
对我来说，我的孩子，我有一个八岁的和一个六岁的。我们陷入了正餐僵局、零食僵局。他们吃同样的零食。比如，我在想莉亚的孩子们有没有尝过芝士条（Cheez-It）或水果零食，或者呼啦棒（fruit strip / hula bars）。我的意思是，莉亚，我们的孩子们喜欢 GoGo SqueeZ。你还记得 GoGo SqueeZ 吗？它基本上就像苹果酱，但装在一个小袋子里，他们可以拧开盖子，
and it's easy for them to hold, and they just squeeze it in their mouth. Doesn't Jennifer Garner have, like, a whole line of, like, delicious, organic, squeezable snacks? Once Upon a Farm, I follow her on Instagram. You know, she's such a doll. Yeah, I do, too. And she's always talking about them. But, you know, my kids are older now. That wouldn't be for them.
而且他们很容易拿着，直接挤进嘴里就行了。詹妮弗·加纳（Jennifer Garner）是不是有全系列的好吃、有机、可挤压零食？Once Upon a Farm，我在 Instagram 上关注她。你知道，她真是一个甜心。是的，我也是。她总是谈论这些。但是，你知道，我的孩子现在长大了。那不适合他们。
I don't know how old Leah's kids are. I've got a good snack rut breaker. What is it? This is something my mom used to give me and I give to my kids. It's healthy, nutritious. It's very sweet. It's an apple cheese flour. Cut slices of apple, slices of cheese, and arrange them in a little petal formation,
我不知道莉亚的孩子多大。我有一个很好的零食僵局打破法。是什么？这是我妈妈以前给我吃的东西，我也给我的孩子们吃。它很健康、有营养。它非常甜。这是一个苹果奶酪花。切出苹果片，切出奶酪片，然后把它们排列成小花瓣的形状，
alternating around. That's very cute. I used to make peanut butter and jelly sandwiches and I had a little heart cookie cutter and I would cut them in a little heart. I do want to say this, that. if you like to make sort of snacks at home and not buy them, and this is a very easy recipe, but our kids loved it when Josh, you pick whatever fruit that your kids love, and he would make a homemade sorbet. Where you freeze it.
交替环绕。这太可爱了。我以前做花生酱果冻三明治时，有一个小爱心饼干模具，我会把它切成小爱心。我确实想说这个，如果你喜欢在家里做一些零食而不是买现成的，这是一个非常简单的食谱，但我们的孩子非常喜欢，当乔什——你挑选你的孩子喜欢的任何水果，他会做一个自制冰沙（sorbet）。在你冷冻它之后。
Where you freeze it, and then you could scoop out a little bit so we would do like strawberry or mango, watermelon, and it's a very simple recipe. Well, my kids loved just straight frozen blueberries. My daughter still likes them. They also love frozen peas. Oh. Just a bag of frozen peas. Roseberry crackers and frozen peas, call it a day.
当你冷冻它之后，然后你可以挖出一小部分，所以我们会做草莓或芒果、西瓜口味的，这是一个非常简单的食谱。嗯，我的孩子们喜欢直接吃冷冻蓝莓。我女儿现在还是很喜欢。他们也喜欢冷冻豌豆。哦。就是一袋冷冻豌豆。迷迭香饼干和冷冻豌豆，搞定收工。
Well, and then their other favorite snack was if you slice a banana, and they still eat this one, too. And then you put a little dollop of peanut butter on each slice and then put a single chocolate chip on top. They love it. Our kids loved that, and then they would put a little bit of honey. A little bit of honey. Yeah. And then now this isn't a snack, but it was like our go-to lunch for so long. In fact, we made it one time and brought it over to your house, Jenna, and then your kids loved it.
嗯，然后他们另一个最喜欢的零食是如果你切一片香蕉，他们现在也还在吃这个。然后在每一片上放一小团花生酱，接着在顶部放上一粒巧克力豆。他们超爱。我们的孩子很喜欢这个，然后他们会加一点点蜂蜜。一点点蜂蜜。是的。然后，现在这不是零食，但它曾是我们很长一段时间以来的固定午餐。事实上，我们有一次做好后带到了你家，珍娜，然后你的孩子们非常喜欢。
Octopus hot dog? So my husband called it octopus, and he would take hot dogs and cut them into a little round pieces and then put the pasta through the middle. And then you just boil the whole thing. And then they just can pick it up and eat it with their hands, too, when they're little. They just pick up the little octopus spaghetti hot dog thing. I remember your son, Jack, introduced that to my kids and they flipped out for it. Yeah. So sweet.
章鱼热狗？所以我丈夫叫它章鱼，他会把热狗切成小圆片，然后把意大利面穿过中间。然后你把整个东西煮熟。接着他们就可以用手拿起来吃，尤其是小的时候。他们就拿起那个小章鱼意面热狗吃。我记得你儿子杰克把那个介绍给我的孩子们，他们为之疯狂。是的。太甜了。
Well, I'm always looking for ways to avoid all of the like preservatives and additives that are in the kind of like mass produced snacks. So one of the things my kids love also, we would do these for breakfast, but they would also become a snack are mini pancake muffins. Yes. So I would just make a homemade pancake mix. I just found one on the internet. Yeah. I bake it in a mini muffin tin. Yeah.
嗯，我一直在寻找方法，以避免那种批量生产的零食中含有的所有防腐剂和添加剂。所以我的孩子们也很喜欢的一样东西，我们经常把它当早餐，但它们也可以作为零食，那就是迷你松饼。是的。所以我只会做一个自制的松饼面糊。我刚在网上找到的。是的。我把它烤在一个迷你松饼盘里。是的。
And then I pop the whole bag of those in the freezer. And then you just get them out and you can put them in the microwave for five seconds. And they're just like little – it's a pancake, but it's a pancake muffin. But I made it at home so there's no like preservatives in it. Yeah. No, those are great. Yeah. Anything mini like that is so good.
然后我把整袋东西都扔进冷冻室。接着你只要拿出来，在微波炉里热五秒钟就行了。它们就像小小的——这是一个松饼，但它是一个松饼形状的迷你蛋糕。而且是我在家里做的，所以里面没有防腐剂。是的。不，那些太棒了。是的。任何诸如此类的迷你版东西都太棒了。
This was like a parent fail. I was trying to get Isabel to eat cauliflower, like to try. try it. And there's no way in heck. She was going to eat cauliflower. She was little. So I read on some mommy blogger site that you can bake it, you know, with like a little bit of olive oil, a little bit of salt, and kind of tear it apart in little pieces. It kind of looks like popcorn. Okay. So I did that. And I tried it. I thought it tastes great. I put it in a bowl. This is like probably horrible parenting. But I was like, this one, you want to try this? It's like a type of popcorn. Oh, no. So I should have never said like, compared to it.
这是一个家长的失败经历。我当时试图让伊莎贝尔（Isabel）吃花椰菜，就是让她尝试一下。但她绝对不可能吃花椰菜。她当时还小。所以我从某个妈妈博客网站上看到，你可以把它烤一下，你知道的，加一点点橄榄油，一点点盐，然后把它撕成小块。它看起来有点像爆米花。好吧。所以我照做了。我试了一下。我觉得味道很棒。我把它装进碗里。这可能算是糟糕的育儿方式。但我当时想，这个，你想尝尝吗？这是一种爆米花。哦，不。所以我绝不应该说——把它和爆米花作比较。
pared it to popcorn. So she puts it in her mouth and she goes, da, not popcorn. It was like, furious. I was like, oh, crap. Have you seen those plates that they've made now to help your kids at dinner time where it looks like a little racetrack and you fill in the little spots with different foods? And then when they get to the end, there's like a little covered spot and you take the cover off and it reveals a treat. Like, that's where the little dessert is. Oh, my gosh.
和爆米花作比较。所以她把它放进嘴里，然后说，不，这不是爆米花。她简直气急败坏。我就想，哦，糟了。你见过现在为孩子们晚饭时间设计的那些盘子吗？它看起来像一个小赛车跑道，你在不同的格子里填上不同的食物？然后当他们走到终点时，有一个小盖子盖着的地方，你把盖子掀开，就会出现一个惊喜。就像，甜点就在那儿。哦，天哪。
This feels a little bit like dog training. Well, we got these when our kids were little. And what we did was we alternated between, like, two things we knew were a winner and then, like, one new thing. So, you know, or one thing that maybe they weren't as enthusiastic about. So we'd put, like, you know, a little chicken nugget, a little macaroni and a piece of broccoli. and then a chicken nugget, macaroni, piece of broccoli, and you go down the little line until you get to whatever the treat was. But the treats covered up.
这感觉有点像驯狗。嗯，我们在孩子们小的时候买过这些。我们做的方法是，在两个我们知道稳赢的食物之间交替，然后放一个新食物。所以，你知道的，或者一个他们可能没那么热衷的食物。所以我们会放，你知道的，一个小鸡块，一点通心粉和一小块西兰花。然后又是一个鸡块、通心粉、西兰花，你就沿着这条小路一直走，直到你到达奖励的地方。但是奖励是被盖住的。
Oh. So there's like, it kind of made it fun. But can they just lift it before the race is over? They could. Yes. As things go, these plates work once, maybe twice, right? Like, they work for a hot second. Right.
哦。所以有点像，这让事情变得有趣。但他们能在比赛结束前就把盖子掀开吗？他们可以。是的。事情往往如此，这些盘子管用一次，也许两次，对吧？就像，它们只管用那么一会儿。对。
But that was another little thing we did. And every once in a while, they'd get excited about it. They'd be like, oh, can we do the race? car played again. Sure, yeah. Sure, yeah. We sort of went all over the place, but we just hope you're well and we hope your kids are happy and we hope there's a snack here that you heard that you can try at home. Yes. Tell them the office lady's set to try it. Oh, no. Well, everyone, I think that wraps it up. Yeah. Thanks for hanging out with us on this Friday
但那是我们做的另一件小事。偶尔，他们会为此感到兴奋。他们会说，哦，我们能再玩一次赛车盘子吗？当然，可以。当然，可以。我们聊了很多，但我们只是希望你一切都好，希望你的孩子们快乐，也希望这里有你能听到并在家里尝试的零食。是的。告诉他们办公室女士说的可以试一试。哦，不。好吧，各位，我想今天的节目就到这里了。是的。谢谢大家陪我们度过这个周五
chit-chat. We hope you have a great one. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
闲聊。希望你们过得愉快。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Odyssey 出品，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是爱因斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbico）。Odyssey 的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。